tilman alors gérard vous allez nous
faire découvrir aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
appelle les jardins familiaux
oui les jardins familiaux vous en
souvenez sans doute jean claude ce sont
en fait les anciens jardins ouvriers qui
ont été créé en 1896 la fin du siècle
dernier donc par l'abbé lemire
un des buts est récurent et progressif
disons le qui avait créé les premières
lois sociales comme la limitation des
horaires des travaux pour les enfants
les femmes et puis aussi le repos
dominical
alors on retrouve ces jardins autour des
banlieues industrielles avec leur
gloriette savez c'est à dire leur petite
cabane est aussi disons dans les dents
les pourtours des sites est assez
importante notamment de l'est du nord du
val de loire
alors il y en a il y en a actuellement
150 milles mais c'est peu par rapport
aux 700 milles qu'il y avait à la
libération et le dernier à paris et mort
à succomber de sa belle mort n'est pas
terrien belle marie lesage alors il est
mort l'an novembre dernier à paris dont
13 ème arrondissement la moyenne des
jardins et de 200 à 250 mètres carrés
c'est suffisant il y en ait foule
souligné alors qu'il y en a 150 mille
chez nous 650 millions pologne et je
crois qu'ils aident beaucoup à
l'alimentation l'heure actuelle et il y
en a 600 milles en allemagne dont 25
minutes c'est énorme
aïe que pour brême alors nous avons
voulu voir ce qui se passe en france
ils ont visité un groupe modeste dans la
banlieue de montbéliard vous allez voir
cette annexion fois réussi deux passions
et d'amitié dans un groupe de soixante
jardin
dans la plus grande usine de france
voici rose plus qui j'ai chargé des
statistiques de défaut car il y as avec
toutes les options 22000 type de
véhicule peugeot
autre bâtiment le calme austère du
bureau des appareils de mesure voilà
celui qui les commandent joseph berthold
détail rose et joseph ne se rencontrent
jamais dans cette fourmilière de 31
mille employés
une heure après changement de décor à
deux pas de l'usiné
les soixante jardins familiaux des hlm
de grand-charmont plus de cravate mais
un chapeau de paille
nous avons la nature nous aimons une
autre petit coin de terre à nous on peut
en jouir
quand bon nous semble tombe par exemple
moi viagym ya aussi souvent que je peux
et même très très souvent j'y suis pas
pratiquement tous les soirs si le pas
trop fort je j'y suis tous les samedis
pratiquement toute la journée une bonne
partie des vacances le dimanche de temps
en temps j bien passé mais mes repas on
ya pique-niqué ici matin ce jeudi à midi
et soir disait alors on dit des
jardiniers parfois qu'ils écoutent
poussé dans légumes c'est oui c'est vrai
oui oui c'est vrai on écoute pousser nos
légumes c'est à dire que moi je dis on
écoute craqué pendant que les poireaux
craquelé bull centraux choc car ici tout
est prétexte à réunir les amis les
voisins
un jardinier m'a même confié qu'il
appelle ses lopins sont ils de réunion
ce n'est pas qu'une image voilà joseph
berthold qui ayant sélectionné quelques
plants de salades va les offrir un rose
fluo iger et quand une main verte
rencontre une autre main verte qu'est ce
qui se raconte et c'est ainsi dans nos
150 mille jardins familiaux qui étaient
700 milles à la libération
lentement sûrement ils sont étranglés
par les 3b béton bitume bagnols dommage
qu'est ce que vous allez en faire de
tous ses radis roses
tdu quoi la wii ne l'a pas été chanceux
que louis a fait beaucoup de son joyau
fait des changes de celui d'auckland
beaucoup de choses et puis on s'entraide
sa nouveau monde comme la connais pas
quelque chose qu'on va trouver le voisin
tout de suite on est renseigné on est
oui on est très bien c'est bien bon bah
alors je vous laisse casser la croûte
parce que c'est leur venons de nancy
cette famille s'est intégré à
montbéliard sochaux notamment grâce aux
jardins jardin d'ailleurs aidé par
peugeot en plus de l'économie procurer
au budget familial jusqu'à 5000 francs
par an le rôle populaire sociale du
jardin est évident important l'anonymat
s'ils brisent les conflits ils sont
gommées les barrières sautent les
contraintes disparaissent les
collectivités locales
on clique intérêt d'ailleurs à
s'orienter dans leur équipe en vert le
jardin familial puisqu'il répond à tous
les objectifs et à toutes les fonctions
de des espaces verts classiques alors
que il coûte beaucoup moins cher à
l'investissement et que l'entretien il
coûte pratiquement rien puisqu'ils sont
pris en charge par les associations qui
en assurent l'administration et la
gestion
la demande est énorme elle avoisine le
million de jardin et c'est possible avec
25000 créations par an alors qu'on en
fait qu'un sens dérisoire rapidement
donc il faut que les collectivités
locales versent les subventions qu'elles
doivent verser
sinon ce sera la fin des haricots